there you look at gio gonzalez on for
his fifth game his fourth start era a
touch above six and a half
and a wave at a mid strike three good
curve ball from geo gonzalez one gone
so let's see how he adjusts to the
curveball here
check swing yes he did strike three he
did not adjust to that curveball and
gio's got two strikeouts but it's going
to be very interesting evening because
matthew boyd does throw the long ball in
fact he's thrown five home runs in 19 in
the third innings
high fly ball center field jones back at
the track another home run
yesterday was fun how about some more
one nothing sucks right out of the gate
deja vu all over again as tim anderson
leads off the game with a home run to
center and the white sox jump out to a
one-nothing lead you know we just got to
keep talking tim anderson up because he
seems to have the vibe from us
[Applause]
this is a fly ball well struck right
center did they do it again back to back
yes sir
two for the price of one here we go
again
number five on the year from oncotta and
a quick two-nothing lead for the chicago
white sox over the tigers oh
yakatau city
with washington grandahl swings and
misses out number one comes three
batters in
and the 2-2 to jimenez got him chase it
up high
second strikeout of the inning for
matthew boyd
he goes
boyd strikes out the side but gives up a
couple of homers
steve stone private eye swing and a miss
strike three
swinging at a miss strike three geo goes
with the change up he's got four
strikeouts in an inning and two thirds
so back to the top of the order and tim
anderson loves to swing the bat
it's going to be a slider
into right field well hit maven back at
the wall tim did it again
tim anderson the bane of matthew boyd's
existence it's three nothing socks
so tim's now hit four and he's driven in
four
and a prolonged at bat
ends out of the ballpark
fourth time he's had a multi-homer gamer
getting the blood flowing a little bit
another one two to swung on and missed
but chicago tacks on another one 33
pitches in each of the first two for
matthew boyd
he got another swing and a miss for
strike three another change up again
that's the different look that's what a
veteran can do who has a full arsenal
throw to second oh they got him
beautifully done
geo cuts down reyes
he was way
off the bag he was past the county line
one two him then
right down the middle that's the
second time matthew boyd
has knocked out eloy jimenez
and now he's pitching away
that's an 11 pitch inning for matthew
boyd
exactly what he needed
the 3-1 to cabrera that's a rifle shot
to left and a base hit a 304 lifetime
hitter against gonzalez
weights on the payoff
that's a hard rope right in front of
jimenez
back-to-back singles for the tigers to
start the fourth and jonathan scope is
two for two oh and two
uh swinging a miss strike three so
candelario continues to struggle to make
contact and one down
one two
it's there strike three a curve ball
locked him up
another opportunity for esau paredes
the 3-2
a line drive and that's going to drop
cabrera trots home with the tigers first
run and jonathan scope follows it's 3-2
thanks to esoc paredes
first major league hit it drives in two
and pulls the tigers to within one
well he got jammed again but he was able
to put the ball in play great job he
fought off some good pitches took some
close pitches but just get a little
blooper jam job and way to go looked
like a line drive for his whole life
two strikes to reyes he struck him out
and the sox maintain the lead
got him this wave and a miss
mazzara goes down swinging
the strikeouts lighting up your score
sheet for matthew
he struck him out swinging and one gone
and that'll do it third strikeout for
willy castro in the ball game and geo
has 10 strikeouts
gio gonzalez
got to 10 strikeouts in four and two
thirds he is just the second sox pitcher
all time to have 10 strikeouts in fewer
than five innings pitch i gotta think
that luis is gonna have a decent at bat
two and two from roney
swinging a high fly ball left center
field way back there it is out of here
bring him home
you said good at bat how about a great
at bat solo shot luis robert and it's
4-2
look he hung the first slider to him and
then he just hung another one and luis
took the pitch before so very well
danny a laser down the left field line
that is gone a close line
just a buzz saw to left field and it's
five to two
five solo home runs and roney arrived
just in time to see two of them
now look that's ridiculous timing
come on stop it
no
don't be doing that pick and roll eloy
jimenez he looks like wait a second can
i catch a ball every now and then how am
i going to be among the league leaders
and put outs if you take everything this
is hit to eloy i mean it's his ball well
it was his ball it's not going to be his
ball because it's luis's ball these guys
really enjoy what they're doing and as a
team they enjoy one another well in a
season where you can't be at the
ballpark these guys put you at the
ballpark when you were basically age
eight sox win tonight
seven to two ruiz closes out another
sterling affair for the bullpen